hey youtubers is Charlie so Jorge are
Martin did this mega post last night
explaining that wins a winter is going
to be delayed he didn't say when it's
gonna drop he just said that it's not
gonna drop in time for Game of Thrones
Season six so here's an explainer for
what's going on I know it's a total
bummer we won't be able to read wins
winner before season 6 starts but
there's new round of the giveaway so
maybe that'll help a little bit all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so here's the deal based on what Martin
said it sounds like the original plan
was for him to turn in his final draft
of wins a winner to his publisher by the
end of October that would give them time
to publish it by sometime in March
before season 6 started in April and
everybody'd be happy there'd be about a
five-month
turnaround so keep that number in mind
about five months between the time he
turns in his final draft and the time
that they can ship the book throughout
the course of the year though he kept
running into real-world things that took
him away like he had to travel a couple
different places chapters took longer to
complete and he just didn't finish in
time it's a huge book it's gonna take
him a little bit more time to finish
that's actually a pretty normal thing in
the world of publishing if you guys read
comic books Marvel has this big secret
war series they've had to delay the last
couple of issues and it's just a comic
book that's not even like 60 pages long
so I feel like this delay is more of a
WTF for people that have started reading
the books since the show started if
you've been reading the books since
Martin first started publishing them
back in the late 80s then you know all
about delays it took forever for him to
complete dance with dragons when he
first had the idea for Game of Thrones
like before he ever started writing the
books it was only supposed to be a
trilogy but then it started to get
bigger and bigger so he added a couple
more books and then even before the show
had started in 2011 and it turned into
seven books so obviously were on book 6
right now so it's still gonna take him a
couple more years before grimas spring
comes out so at this point it's a
foregone conclusion the game of Thrones
is going to end its run well before he
finishes his last book so big WTF
question does that mean that the TV show
is going to spoil the books and I'll say
not necessarily but yet probably for a
few things Martin as well as Dan and
Dave have both said that the show and
the books are starting to diverge
they're doing very different things even
though they're headed in the same
direction so I think essentially they'll
end in the same place but you'll see a
lot of different characters making it to
the finish line
I'm gonna speculate just a little bit on
where the plots going so I'll say
spoiler warning for everything that's
already happened on the TV show and
maybe spoilers for things that might
happen in the future like I'm just gonna
speculate about a couple of the
characters but just to be clear this is
speculation I haven't seen any season
six episodes yet so in the mythical
future where Jon Snow and Daenerys end
up facing off against the night's king
in the White Walkers does that mean that
we're gonna see that on the TV show like
a couple years before torch our Martin
writes it in his books probably but
that's really only the smallest part of
a very very big story with a giant cast
of characters so be like if you went
into Star Wars The Force awakens and you
like you jumped ahead and you saw the
very end of the movie and you felt like
that ruined the entire thing like the
movie itself like star wars the force
awakens is a great movie it's a lot of
fun there are a lot of characters so
it'd be like saying the entire story is
crap and the only reason you go to see
it is for like the last couple of
minutes so even if you do get spoiled by
the TV show it's like the variant in
season 8 the books are still going to be
amazing and there's always gonna be like
a giant portion of the population that
just hates the show and just wants to
read the books nothing is gonna change
for them that like they were never gonna
care about the show anyway and the
people that only like the show and
aren't ever gonna read the books it
won't matter for them either it's really
when you think about it it's only a
problem for like a very small portion of
the population and even if you guys have
watched my last couple of Game of
Thrones bonus videos I've said that if
you haven't started reading the books it
would actually be kind of confusing if
you tried to read the books and watch
season six at the same time so just wait
till after season 6 episode 10 to start
reading so back to wins a winner
remember that five month period between
the time George R Martin turns in his
last draft in the day that they can ship
the book if Martin is able to finish his
work on the book and turn it in to his
publisher by the start of season 6 Beno
by sometime in April then we'll probably
see the book by early winter 2016 at the
latest now that's it there aren't any
other major delays any unforeseen
problems but the other big thing I saw a
bunch of you guys asking me on Twitter
about was at the very end of Martin's
post is he you know he lists a bunch of
characters that have gone down different
ways in the show than they have in the
books like these characters are dead on
the show but they're alive in the books
then he lists a whole bunch of other
characters like Lady Stoneheart young
Grif that the show has never done just
illustrating some of the huge
differences between the books in the
show some of you asked me if I thought
it was a spoiler that he listed Marcella
and Stannis Baratheon just reading into
it that maybe he was saying that they're
confirmed dead on the TV show he didn't
necessarily confirm they're dead on the
TV show
HBO did release a book that that had
some language in it that made it sound
like Stannis was definitely dead
usually they make it a little more
ambiguous till the start of the season I
never really thought that they were
gonna make it so I did think that they
were dead after the end of season 5 but
that's not a confirmation or anything
that's just me reading into the story
the way I think about it if there's a
character that's going to be coming back
into the story in taking this big big
leadership role then what was Stannis
going to be doing he's not really a
backseat character so it's not like he's
gonna ride shotgun to another character
who is rising up during season six so
really from a story perspective as as
well as a budget perspective just from
you know practical concerns it makes
sense for the TV show to just get rid of
the character just sidestep any
potential logic issues that they'll run
into but let me know in the comments
what do you think about George RR
Martin's delay what wins a winner like
do you think it's totally normal are you
really upset
it's totally okay to be upset with it
but I don't think it's gonna ruin the
story or anything like it's not like Dan
and Dave have red winds of winter and
they did episodes based on that plot
really I think what's going on with
season six is they have an idea of where
the characters are headed in season six
is just their interpretation of that but
because the cast of characters wins the
winner is so different the way that
plays out is going to be a little bit
different even though it's headed in the
same direction so hopefully that
explains what's going on a little bit
folks take forever to write it's George
R Martin working with a couple people
but the TV show has a couple of
different armies of people making it so
of course it's gonna be happening faster
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner William Thornton you win a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info what's gonna
happen next is because we're into
January I probable ittle bit more time
for q and A's so I'll actually try and
do a game of Thrones Q&A in the next day
or two
whenever questions you guys have about
the books or the TV show just put them
in the comments just in case you guys
haven't seen it HBO dropped this brand
teaser that implies a few things about
season six you can click here for that
and you can click here for my top ten
crazy Star Wars Episode seven theories
thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you